[Music]
hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science
chemistry phd and skin care nerd
yesterday i was looking at my blog
archives and i realized it's been
a little bit over a year since i last
shared my evening skincare routine
i get a lot of questions on what
products i've been using in my routine
and i usually just tell people to look
at that post but i realize i haven't
actually read that post in a while
so i thought it would be interesting to
have a look at that and see what
products i'm still using which products
i've changed
and whether or not i still agree with
the opinions of michelle from
about 16 months ago if you like nerding
out about the science behind beauty
products make sure you click subscribe
and click the notification bell so you
don't miss any videos
so here's what i said in my post i don't
like sharing my routine that often
because i'm testing products and i don't
want to endorse something that i haven't
fully tested yet
that is still the case i still have to
test lots of products and
yeah i feel a little bit uncomfortable
sharing it before i've really had
a proper opinion also when i share it a
lot of people tend to ask me what i feel
about that product
and i'm usually not quite ready yet when
i'm ready i will post a review
secondly it's because i think it's
tempting for people to see my routine
and try to copy it exactly
my skin's needs aren't the same as
another person's skin's needs
my budget and products that are
available aren't the same as someone
else
i still completely agree with this you
need to know your own skin
products that will work for me won't
necessarily work for
you especially if you don't have the
same skin type and skin conditions as i
do
in my opinion the most sensible route is
to get to know your skin and its needs
then base a routine on that
and your budget and product
accessibility yes completely still agree
with that you need to know your skin you
need to
understand it and then you can pick
products without having to necessarily
just
base it on other people's
recommendations that's why the lab
muffin guide to
basic skincare starts with instructions
on how to perform a skin assessment
yes doing a skin assessment is really
important you want to know what your
skin is like
if it's dry oily sensitive dehydrated
in the absence of whatever products
you're using a lot of people tend to use
too
many products and then their skin might
react to that
so yeah a lot of people are using
products that make their skin
worse than it might be if you use less
products or
even if you use no products at all you
can't work out what your skin needs if
you're using products that aren't right
for your skin then piling products
suited to someone else's skin on top you
just can't
completely agree with that as well so
there's a third reason i don't really
share my routine that often
and it's because i do get a lot of pr
samples and like i said i am usually
testing some products
i think a lot of skincare instagramers
tend to share their routines and it will
be
like 10 products and half of them will
change
every single day and i think that's kind
of misleading to people
skin care influences should be people
who know more about skin care or at
least
are more immersed in that world and i
think it gives
people who are less experienced a
misleading
idea of how many products should be in a
routine and how often you should be
changing them out
so i try not to do that i don't have an
eta for my next skincare ebook
about advanced skincare routines and
actives that is still the case
i have started working on it it is in
progress but
i don't know i never know how long
things take so the next section is some
general notes about my routine they're
more principles that guide me
rather than strictly what's in my
routine my routine isn't rigid i adapt
it based on how my skin feels
that's still the case i will pick
products based on whether my skin's
feeling tight dry
what the weather is like as well to
adapt your routine effectively you need
to know how to assess your skin and know
how your skin reacts to specific
products which is why i go on about
one product at a time still the case so
here are the considerations for my
personal routine that shape what i
choose
and these will be different for everyone
my top priorities are anti-acne and
anti-pigmentation
that hasn't changed i still get acne
i've actually had a really
nasty breakout here for a few weeks now
so
yep that's still going on i'm turning 32
this year
so young so i'm starting to see more
white hairs and wrinkles
i am seeing more white hairs but since
last time i don't think the wrinkles
have really progressed which is awesome
my skin is oily and dehydration prone i
prefer not to layer too many products
yep still the case too many steps gets
confusing and heavy and increases the
chances of the products interacting and
clumping up or irritating my skin
and it takes longer than i can handle
still correct
after cleansing i like to use less than
four products i think the average has
actually gone down a bit
since then i think i generally use two
or three
i don't like things that are unpleasant
to use even if they're more effective i
like to enjoy my skincare routine
i favor products with convenient
packaging and easy application
over things that i'm a pain to use still
true
i also like pleasant textures and scents
yes
i don't have brand loyalty i mix and
match products from different brands all
the time
that's definitely correct there are
still products and brands that show up
multiple times yes so i think
part of this is brands that i tend to
like more
and have more um reliable products
but i think part of it is also just some
brands have more products and more
categories
and so i end up using more of their
products as well just because i don't
regularly use a product i've loved in
the past doesn't mean i no longer
recommend it sometimes products just
fall by the wayside as a similar product
has replaced it and i haven't felt the
need to repurchase it
sometimes i switched to a different
product and forgotten how good it was
and then later on i rediscover it and go
on a rave
i think that is going to happen in this
video so the next section
is about cleansing last year i cleanse
with an oil cleanser than a gentle
foaming cleanser i shower at night so i
step into the shower with oil cleanse on
my face then
step into the shower for the foaming
cleanser that's still
pretty much my routine even during
lockdown i use a lot of different
cleansers but they're always gentle
yep that's still correct so here are the
cleansers i used last year
um i currently use none of these and
mostly because i
finished them off so i finished off the
shure mirror
i loved it still love it but now i'm
using other things
pharmacy green clean that's a cleansing
balm also finished that peter thomas
ralph finished it
crave beauty i don't think i completely
finished the bottle but then i got
distracted and started using something
else but i think i finished
most of it paula's choice hydrating gel
to cream cleanser
i actually used half of it and then i
gave the rest of the tube to my sister
because she's got drier skin
and this suited her better with the
youth to the people one
i finished it and then i discovered the
pump fits on lush
shower gels which is amazing one of the
things i really didn't like about the
youth to the people cleanser is that it
was in a glass jar
and as someone who cleanses their face
in the shower that was
an accident waiting to happen so i
couldn't wait to finish that off and get
it out of the shower i actually kept it
on the floor of the shower
so that there was a lower chance of it
just breaking and
cutting my feet open if i'm wearing
heavy makeup i might use a tool for
cleansing
the panasonic micro foaming facial
cleansing brush was my favorite
that is still my favorite and that's
because it has
these massaging balls instead of the
usual brush
and so that means if you use it every
day you're much less likely to get
irritated
i know a lot of people who start using
cleansing brushes want to use them every
day because they're quite convenient for
getting cleanser on your face and
foaming it up
but for most people that tends to be a
bit too harsh
so this avoids it really nicely but now
i
really rarely wear heavy makeup so i
don't really bother so i decided for
this video i would only show
products that i've been using for at
least a month in terms of the
cleansing oils and balms this is the
cleansing balm i've been using
it is the then i met you living
cleansing balm
this is a really gorgeous texture
i really like it it has a really rich
texture which i enjoy
i probably wouldn't use it without
following up with some sort of firming
cleanser
the other cleansing balm i've been using
is the ordinary squalane cleanser
this is pretty much a cleansing farm in
a tube it's a bit less oily than your
usual cleansing bum or at least that's
how it feels on my skin
still works really well i probably would
prefer and cleansing oil in a pump but
at the moment that's what i'm doing in
terms of foaming cleansers i've been
using the then i met you soothing tea
cleansing gel
which i really like and i think this is
why i've forgotten about the crave
beauty one because they're pretty
similar products they're in
the same shape packaging and they look
the same when you squeeze it out the
other cleanse i've been using a lot is
the neutrogena ultra gentle daily
cleanser
i was testing this for a sponsored video
this video isn't sponsored but that one
is
and i really love it it's got glycerin
really high up in the ingredients list
so it's really hydrating which is good
for my skin
and it's in a pump and i just have a
massive bias towards things and pumps
because they're so convenient
another product that i've been using for
cleansing is
the bio essence by water micellar water
this is one of the most effective
micellar waters i've ever used
a lot of the time micellar water it
doesn't work that great around your eyes
but this one just sort of destroys
makeup which is amazing
it also feels quite normal on your skin
so
it feels like you don't need to rinse it
off so yeah this is super convenient i
use this a lot on nights when i'm too
lazy to properly cleanse my face
onto the actives part so i use the three
night cycle for my leave on evening
products tretinoin night alpha hydroxy
acidity and vitamin c night
i still use a three night cycle
tretinoin night is always in there
the other two nights have changed a bit
but generally there will be one harsh
exfoliating night
and one gentle nicer night recovery
night
so tretinoin i'm still using it is still
the same generic brand which we get here
in australia it is
0.05 so last year i said it was
fantastic at keeping breakouts at bay
fading hyperpigmentation and smoothing
out skin texture
it's probably also keeping wrinkles away
i think it probably is keeping the
wrinkles away because i haven't really
seen any increase in wrinkles maybe
there's even been a decrease
in terms of breakouts i don't think i've
really seen a decrease
i did also start using oral
contraceptives between then and now
so it's a bit hard to say for sure but i
tend to feel that
tretinoin doesn't really keep away my
clogged pores it's really the chemical
exfoliants
last year i said that my skin was still
super sensitive to tretinoin
so thankfully it is a lot less sensitive
now i
hardly ever get massive peeling i still
only use it every three days
maybe i've just gotten better at
estimating how much i need
so i used to mix a quarter to a half pea
sized blob of tretinoin with a few drops
of oil
now i tend to mix it with moisturizer
instead of oil
i haven't really used oils that much
recently
so when i was originally filming this
video it was locked down and so i wasn't
really leaving the house much but
now i am going to and from work every
day and it's the middle of winter so i
am using oils because my skin
is getting a little bit flaky i usually
use rosehip oils or a blend of oils and
i'll add a couple of drops to my
moisturizer or i'll put it on my hands
and then press them together then press
them into my face
and i know that wastes a lot of product
but i don't really mind because
i never use up oils before they go off
so here are the moisturizers i tend to
use the most
the laneige cream skin toner and
moisturizer this
is sort of like a really light liquid
lotion
i used this a lot in summer when it was
a bit too hot and sticky to use a
moisturizer properly
but i still wanted something to hydrate
and add a little bit of oil to my skin
so this is really handy this is the
small bottle i actually also have a
giant bottle as well i mostly mix
tretinoin with moisturizer so that it
spreads a lot more easily so i don't
feel the need to
use extra treatment or get too much in
one particular spot
so i've been using these three
moisturizers the most so firstly the
jordan samuel skin
performance cream this was sent to me by
jordan samuel who is an aesthetician in
the u.s
so this is a really nice hydrating
moisturizer and it actually has a whole
bunch of peptides in it
so it has actives but it doesn't really
feel like it has actors which i really
like
there's also biogeomers sensor biolite i
really like bioderma creams for when
i don't want my face to react with
anything i know that my skin
will be fine with them and so i use this
a lot
then i also have this one which is the
newest one in my collection
dr dennis gross's stress repair face
cream so this is quite interesting
because it has a lot of adaptogens
i haven't really looked that much into
them for skin care but they do
have antioxidant properties a lot of the
time so this has a pretty strong ginger
smell
it's very hydrating and i mostly use it
because of the texture
dr dennis gross's products tend to have
quite a few naturals in them
but i found that my skin doesn't react
to them which is great that might not be
the same for you
so option two for treasure no night is a
gentle cream
if my skin's too flaky or irritated i
use kate ryan's total nutrition night
repair complex instead this is still one
of my favorite products
i actually have a new jar of it now it
has new packaging
it was in my 2019 favorites and it is
still a favorite
my skin doesn't really get irritated so
much anymore so i use treasure on
consistently every third night i tend to
use this a lot on nights before i want
my skin to look really
good so i actually used it last night so
night two of my cycle is alpha hydroxy
acid night and i said that i still find
that i get some whiteheads if i don't
use hydroxyl acid exfoliants regularly
that's still the case now this is
especially important if i'm trying out
sunscreens
yes that is still true sunscreen still
clogged the crap out of my pores
so last year i said that low ph
hydroxyacetic exfoliants tend to be
irritating on my retinoid skin
but i tended to use a bunch of different
strengths including some really
gentle ones so back then i used to apply
a nice cinnamite serum first
i don't really do this anymore on
hydroxyacin night i used to use 10
percent niacinamide booster or leechy
ham vitapropolis ampule
i've actually stopped using both of
those i really love the paula's choice
ten percent nice cinematic booster it
was the first nice cinema product that i
used
and worked really well on my skin and i
could actually see the benefit
i don't know why i stopped using it i
think i just forgot about it
maybe i should go back to it i think
also a lot of the products i've been
testing
tend to have niacinamide in them
nowadays so maybe
i think i just sort of feel like i'm
getting enough nice cinnamon
but i'm definitely not getting ten
percent two percent bha
liquid i still use this it was one of my
first skin care products my first real
skincare purchase
still love it still use it then i picked
the strongest aha product i can handle
that night and layer it on top sometimes
i'll skip aj altogether if my skin's too
irritated
so back then my high strength one was
ultraceutical's outer brightening serum
that is still
in my stash i still use it here it is
one of the things i really don't like
about this
is that i think the acid is a bit too
strong for the packaging
sometimes so the edges of the mirrored
surfaces
tend to start cracking and the mirrored
paint starts peeling off
and it goes really brown i think they
have a few botanicals in this
which can oxidize the product itself is
awesome
it's just the packaging i could really
do with a bit of improvement
then for medium strength i used to use
paula stress eight percent aha or drunk
elephant brand boost glycolic night
serum and low strength i use crave
beauty called
or pixi glow tonic my skin's gotten a
lot less irritated now that it's gotten
used to the tretinoin
so i actually hardly ever use the low
strength ones anymore on my face
i use them on my armpits as deodorant
though i have a blog post on that which
i'll link in the description
i haven't really used a medium strength
one in a while i've started using more
p50 lotion which i bought when i was in
paris
it has gluconolactone which is a
polyhydroxy acid
that's supposed to be less irritating
but still have similar effects
um lactic acid tons of glycerin
niacinamide
yeah so i tend to use a tiny amount of
this because it was
pretty expensive and difficult to get
i'll still probably not finish this
bottle for like
seven years another acid product i've
been using a bit more
is dr dennis gross's alpha beta
universal daily peel
and this i think it's mostly just
convenience
it is a two-step product where you have
two sachets
one sachet is exfoliate and smooth and
the other one is anti-aging neutralizer
so the
exfoliate and smooth contains mostly
glycolic acid and salicylic acid
the key things in step two are ascorbic
acid a few retinoids
ubiquinone which is also known as
coenzyme q10
vitamin e resveratrol so two more
antioxidants
i mostly use this when i'm staying at my
boyfriend's house which we're allowed to
do
in new south wales the neat thing about
these is that
with one of these i can do my face my
back his
face his back and so i feel a lot less
like i'm wasting the product because
there is quite a lot of liquid in this
it actually says you're meant to massage
the pad on your skin until it's dried
out
but i don't think my skin really needs
that much
so on exfoliant night i tend to use one
of those exfoliants and then follow up
with moisturizer
so the third night last year was my
vitamin c night
it makes a huge difference to how
quickly my acne mouths fade
i used to pair this with two percent bha
and i used a bunch of different
elastobic acid products depending on how
irritated my skin was
on night three i found that recently i
haven't really been using vitamin c and
i think that's because i haven't really
had that much
post-inflammatory hyperpigmentation so
those are the brown
marks that you have after your acne has
faded away i do have a breakout here but
it's not really at the stage where it's
starting to become pigmented it's still
trying to heal from the deep clogs
one of the things i've noticed about my
vitamin cs is that i've forgotten how
long i've had it open for
which i think is just a beauty blogger
issue
you get sent vitamin c products you try
them out
and then you put them aside and you
can't remember when you opened it
so i tend to go for this sort of product
which is anhydrous that means it doesn't
have water in it this is paula's choice
c25 super booster
and it's like a gritty product where
the vitamin c is mixed in with a
silicone so with this sort of product
because the vitamin c isn't with water
it doesn't decompose anywhere near as
fast
and so this one i haven't actually used
in a while but
not sure if you can see it when you
squeeze it out it is
almost still entirely white well it's a
really pale beige color
if it was a water-based serum this would
be dark brown for sure by now
but because it's in the silicone base
without any water it's doing fine
so if you're someone who doesn't really
use vitamin c that often i would
recommend something like this
the problem is sometimes if you put it
on your skin
the gritty vitamin c doesn't really
dissolve
that evenly and so you end up with
little hot spots it might get a bit
itchy
and so when i use this i mix it with
some sort of hydrating toner so that it
dissolves on your skin
immediately and you can spread it around
this is my favorite one which is your
lace activating water essence
this has been one of my favorites for
ages um it is quite expensive but
i find that it's really good at
hydrating at a lot of different levels
you can get something similar with a
cheaper product which just has glycerin
this has tons of different humectants
and i find that that just lasts a bit
longer
my skin is super dehydration prone
though another vitamin c product that
i've been using is events a oxidative
serum when i was originally filming i
was still testing this product so i was
testing it for a sponsored blog post
this video isn't sponsored so i wasn't
sure if it was going to stay in my
routine but it's been a few months now
and i still use it once or twice a week
it contains a vitamin c derivative
called ascorbal glucoside and it gets
around some of the problems with
l-ascorbic acid so it's very stable
and that means you don't have to worry
if your product is going off it's also
stable
on your skin and that means you don't
have to worry about staining so that
fake tan looking thing that stains your
fingers and stains your skin and it has
that metallic smell so there's none of
that
it can also be formulated at a higher ph
and still work
which is really good because it means
there's less irritation with a lot of
vitamin c derivatives there's a bit of a
question mark about whether or not they
actually work
so a lot of them need to be converted
back into l-ascorbic acid in your skin
before they'll work
the thing i really like about the event
formulation is that it's actually being
tested to work on skin samples
so it's been found to have the same
antioxidant effect as a fifteen percent
l-ascorbic acid serum so on my third
night instead of vitamin c a lot of the
time now i will use these pecutial
re-face pads from indeed labs
bikuchiol is meant to be an alternative
to rational but it isn't really i talked
about this in my retinal emits video
but it is quite a promising anti-aging
ingredient and so
i've been using this and this also has
tons of niacinamide which my skin
does enjoy i'm not sure how much
niacinamide is actually in these
it is the second ingredient on the
ingredients list so maybe there's quite
a bit
i should probably try the paula's choice
10 again another serum i've been using
on the third night is la clinica's
essentials hydrating and healing serum
so this has niacinamide it has so many
ingredients in it
it's sort of like a really simple
all-in-one serum and
like i said i only like to use one or
two products and so this is really good
it has hyaluronic acid skin essential
which is
an anti-itch ingredient cintella i will
put up a list of all the ingredients on
the screen because this has
like everything that could possibly
hydrate and heal your skin
the really good thing about this is it's
jam packed with ingredients plus it's
got a super light texture
and so it's really easy to pop this on
and then put other things on on top so i
also listed a bunch of other products
that i used as needed
so spot treatments depending on what
spots i have i used
paula's choice four percent bha
hydrocolloid bandages
micro needle patches neutrogena light
therapy acne spot treatment so that's a
light pen
so i still use all of those except the
light pen i think i just got lazy
because you do have to hold the light
pen
over your pimple for about two minutes
hydrating treatments so i use these
around once every two to three weeks in
summer and more frequently in winter
um so i used to use a sheet mask with a
panasonic ionic device
or i used to use an overnight mask i've
gotten lazy and my skin hasn't been
feeling that dehydrated i think because
a lot of my products now have
lots of humectants in them and that
stops my skin from getting dehydrated
i did use an overnight mask when i went
overseas i used the
summer fridays jet lag mask i did also
use rosehip oil when i went overseas as
well but
in sydney i just haven't really felt the
need oil control i used a bunch of
different clay masks i don't use
any of these anymore honestly i feel
like most clay masks are pretty much the
same on my skin
the one i have been using the most is
the flavonoid mud mask from neon
a lot of the actors that neod uses are
kind of
very speculative they don't really have
much solid
evidence to back them up so i appreciate
what they do in terms of trying to be
cutting edge
but at the same time i feel like if i do
have a problem i'm going to go
for the more evidence-backed actives
first the annoying thing is it's in
a small littered jar and so there's
actually a special spoon that you can
use
to scrape out the mud but yeah i am
generally quite lazy so i don't use
masks that often exfoliation catch up if
i've been holding off on alpha hydroxy
acids because of irritation i'll do a
catch up
and the products i used for this used to
be kate somerville's exfoliate
and dermalogica's rapid reveal peel and
i said i used exfolikate more because
it's so shower friendly
now i actually only use exfoliate for
this and it's not really a catch-up
anymore because my skin is so tolerant
to them now
um a lot of the time is actually an
add-on rather than
a substitute so i will use this and an
aha over the course of two or three days
the reason this is so shower friendly is
that it comes out as a pretty
thick paste most of these peel products
are really liquidy like the ordinaries
one or drunk elephants one
or the dermalogica one i used to also
use june jake as perfect pumpkin peeling
enzyme mask
i still really like that product but i
finished it off it smells like pumpkin
pie it's really nice
physical exfoliation one to two times a
week i still do that
and i am still using a peeling gel the
peeling gel i'm using is
gin fu's pineapple peeling gel this was
one of the first ones i tried
and the main selling point of this is
that it works well in the shower where
there's a lot more water
so apart from all of this the only extra
step that i've added in the past year
is using the new face trinity device i
have gotten kind of lazy with it because
i am just a lazy person
it worked really well while i was using
it and i am going to do a proper video
about how it works and what it does
in some point in the future so that is
it for my evening skincare routine it
sounds really long when i list it all
out but really it only takes me
five to ten minutes so i guess the main
differences between
this year and last year is that my skin
has gotten less irritated and sensitive
to tretinoin
which is awesome because then i can use
more of my exfoliating acids
my skin's also gotten less dehydrated
and maybe that's because
the products i've been using have more
humectants in them but conceptually
speaking it's still pretty much the same
routine
it works really well for my skin again
what works for my skin probably won't
work for your skin you should really try
to learn to
understand your skin and incorporate
products that work for you
if you want to find out more about
different types of exfoliants you can
check out my essential guide to
exfoliation which is a free download on
my blog
so i hope you enjoyed this video if you
did you can click the thumbs up
subscribe to my channel
and click the notification bell if you
want me to do a deep dive on any of the
products i've talked about
leave me a comment letting me know which
ones you're most interested in
you can also follow me on instagram lab
muffin beauty science and check out my
blog at labmuffin.com
and i will see you next time for more
beauty science
you